coming up next women are trying to
compete with men and I think that is
literally where the problem is we are
trying to compete with men well that's
exactly I was gonna say I'm gonna go to
like interview people and say you know
what is it I don't think I would take
part in a stock walk no as women we we
just have a lot more to lose and that
there's a lot more at stake for us so
that's why we are naturally gonna be
very you know picky and selective I
think it'd be hard for me to submit to
someone who isn't basically being able
to Lead Me it might sound well that's
not nice but that's how I feel I can't
listen to someone like that
isn't any more than me man and a woman
has complete different duties and roles
than not equal a man's purpose is to to
provide fun and lead and a woman's
purpose is to nurture and produce as
well as I'm concerned for women having
multiple sexual partners is really bad
for your mental health
um it messes up your hormones
biologically
um okay so today's topic is feminism a
disaster so I'd like to go around and
everyone say if you consider yourself a
feminist um yes no and then why
um I'd say no
I'm not a feminist because
I think I believe
I'm in between I would say but I'll say
no because I don't think
there's things that men can do and
there's things that women can't do and
there's things that women can do and
there's things that men can't do if that
makes sense so I feel that's why
I'm in the middle and I'm still seeing a
bit of nah I'm not a feminist
okay
um yeah me I'm I'm similar to Janae
um I don't think I'm a feminist because
I do believe that I am like strong on
like gender roles
um so I do believe that um there's
certain things that a woman should do in
a relationship there's certain things
that man should do in a relationship but
I'm also that big on women empowerment I
just don't feel like it collides yeah
okay go ahead I would say no
um I don't really identify with anything
that feminism stands for anymore
um okay go ahead
um yeah I'm sort of like in between I I
would say I'm very much a traditional
feminist
um not so much a modern feminist
um I still have those Traditional Values
and I feel like I do believe in female
empowerment I do believe in the movement
of feminism
um yeah
okay go ahead yeah I would say I'm sort
of in between as well
but it just gets a bit too technical I
believe in them obviously opening doors
for women but it gets too technical for
me so for me I'm in between as well this
feminists role
I do not consider myself to be a
feminist whatsoever a man and a woman
has complete different duties and roles
they're not equal a man's purpose is to
protect provide hunt and lead and a
woman's purpose is to nurture and
reproduce as far as I'm concerned they
are not equal
I'm not a feminist I'm very in tune with
myself spiritually
and I feel like everything in the modern
day world just really collides with my
spirit so definitely not wow a whole
room not one feminist wow why do you
guys think that is where has it gone too
far
promiscuous he has promoted I think
that's too far I think
for women having multiple sexual
partners is really bad for your mental
health
um it messes up your hormones
biologically
and also like even if you're not
technically sleeping with all of them
what kind of person are you if you're
just an object on millions of people's
screens and all that object is is
your boobs and bum they're not really
seeing you for who you are and if you
don't care about who you are enough to
put that out there and all you want to
put out there is your body and then I
think that shows that maybe there's
something not quite right inside that
maybe you don't value in yourself so you
only value the exterior part of yourself
do you guys know women that can sleep
around and are genuinely happy doing it
no I don't think I've ever met one
really no
no one no so why do you think it's
pushed so much if the outcomes aren't
good for women
because I feel like people
like people that maybe
um this is just like from me watching
but I feel like people that maybe do
sleep around a lot
um maybe if they don't actually like
know who they are or like know what they
stand for completely and they want to
act like they're happy so they'll tell
people yeah this is what makes me happy
this is what I do so you do it too so
it's like it's like some whole gang
thing
um like even Amber Rose for example this
what is that thing she does a nude walk
wow yeah that's that walk out okay oh
yeah would anyone go to a walk
anyone here no okay okay yeah I'll go no
I can't lie I would go for fun like to
watch it I would do interviews like yeah
I'm gonna go to like interview people
and say you know what is it but I don't
think I would take part in a salt walk
no yeah definitely no how do you think
so but yeah what I was gonna say about
the Amber Rose
um suck walk I feel like with feminism
now it's if you show your but the more
body you show the more empowered you are
as a woman and I feel like there's so
much more to that and it's like they try
and talk for all women as a whole when
really this is your opinion so even in
dating now it's like men they'll come
and talk to you in a certain way like
you're a feminist already like they just
think you're a feminist I don't know I
don't explain it but yeah do you think
older women sabotage younger women yeah
yeah
yeah I I feel like going back to what we
were just talking about as well like I
feel like women are trying to compete
with men and I think that is literally
where the problem is we are trying to
compete with men why is it okay for a
man to sleep with loads of women but
it's not okay for me and actually do we
actually enjoy that like we have to
actually ask so ask ourselves like do we
actually enjoy
casually giving our body like that and
you know because we have emotions and we
you know we feel things and like for men
it's different they can go and do that
and have zero emotion whereas with women
it's completely different and we can't
you know deny that so is it though like
do you actually think like do you
actually well most of my friends I feel
like you know they tell me stories and
they sleep with someone and they get
attached like so you don't think men do
or do you think they're just better
hiding their emotions because they don't
no they don't think so no I I meant I'll
go and do that and have a zero emotion
they can do that and and they're
programmed to be like that whereas why
are we trying to compete with that but
but just because someone's programmed to
be like something I don't feel like
they're being completely open and saying
like they can just go and sleep around
with anyone and they don't feel any like
I don't believe that I actually don't I
don't know if they've got to the root of
the problem of why they can do that
because that's not Humane but the thing
is like when money has money power and
Status they do do it so it's like yeah
it's Chris Brown like saying stops no
don't sleep with me of course I love it
but I feel like there's effects that is
just it's not attached to okay you're
seeking with loads of people this is why
you feel like that I feel like they
might feel type of ways but they're not
attaching it to all because I'm just
going around sleeping with loads of
women because I've got loads of male
friends and I see the after effect that
it has with them sleeping with loads of
women but they weren't actually I don't
know yeah they were actually admitting
or pinpoint it on that but I think that
sort of goes back uh that sort of goes
back to like the whole peer pressure
with men and maintaining this image of
like you know when you become successful
and you have money those girls come with
it and I feel like a lot of men are
trying to force that and that's probably
why your friends are feeling some type
of way afterwards because they're doing
something but maybe they don't really
want to be doing it but also I'll be
real like
when men obviously sleep around their
body's not going to change if a woman
sleeps around your body is a temple your
body is going to change it's going to
adapt to whoever you're sleeping with so
that's where you know I mean I'm saying
like Okay the levels of women and men
financially are like the same but
like Following being full of fashion
like it's like
you're the mean like you're lowering
your standards and your body changes
that women we're very reward that to a
man well not me but you know what I'm
saying as for men they just you know I
mean they can go around do what they do
in hunky dory their body's not going to
change a woman's body does change you
know what I mean you're a key so yeah
very true yeah very true and I feel like
as women we we just have a lot more to
lose and that there's a lot more at
stake for us so that's why we are
naturally gonna be very you know picky
and selective and
you know I I pride myself in being
selective and you know not giving my
body freely to just anyone like
do you think you guys could respect a
guy
um and follow his lead if you make more
money than him
um
no I don't mind like in terms of
finances it doesn't make a difference to
me yeah I wouldn't mind if my partner
made more money than me it's as long as
you talk to me with the same level as
respect because I'm still earning you
know so what if you were paying 80 of
the bills and you had to buy a house so
let's say you pay that don't mean yeah
let's say that's it I'm just taking it
to the ex like to the extreme you're
paying 80 of the bills and he says we're
buying this house
and you don't like it you hate it are
you gonna go with it no I thought you'd
have to convince me why we're buying it
you have to make logical sense I I
personally I think that's the the whole
point is that you're not submitting if
he has to convince you that's like if
it's your boss and he tells you to do
something you just do it right so it's I
mean I think when we're being honest
it's hard to submit to someone if they
don't make more money and I feel like a
man is meant to be if you're married
provider we're not Sole Provider but the
provider and I don't feel like if you're
not earning more than me you could
provide for me enough like fully and if
we're buying a house together and I
don't like it I'm not gonna and I'm
providing basically more it's going to
be more my decision I think it'd be hard
for me to submit to someone who isn't
basically being able to lead me you're
gonna have to be able to lead me and if
you're not earning more than me it's
going to be harder for me to agree or
listen to you it might sound oh that's
not nice but that's how I feel I can't
listen to someone that
isn't earning more than me but why is
that the world I just feel like it's
just because of the way I've been raised
if I for example I use my dad he's
always earned he's always been an earner
he's always been able to look after me
and his family so that's what I see my
future husband doing and if you're not
earning more than me maybe if it's a
short period of time you've lost money
or you're down but I couldn't marry
someone that earns less than me I just
couldn't because how I see the role of a
man in a household you're meant to be a
leader provider I just couldn't well I
don't understand sometimes there's a
come up so they might be low yeah
beginning would could you stick by
someone that has a good heart and be
with them through the come up
to be honest with you I thought maybe
because of my past experiences
um I I where I am now I don't want to be
with someone that's on a camera
um I feel like
especially because I have a child and
where I want to be in life I don't want
someone that's going to come up uh maybe
a few years ago it was fine where I am
now I want you to be at least a certain
level and a certain amount of money
consistently I don't want to have to
raise your support you consistently how
much money is it how much money do you
know what it doesn't have to be a large
amount of money because I'm not like
what's the word high maintenance or let
me Google hold on yeah it just Bridge
average salary UK
okay you want everything I feel like
someone just be able to live maintain be
able to go out on events and do things
it doesn't have to be crazy but as long
as you're London 41 000 pounds if he
earns that yeah that's the average says
the average yearly wage for full-time
workers in London in 2022 according to
status
yeah I think that would be fine for me I
don't you don't have to be a millionaire
or a billionaire no way you just have to
be able to support yourself so that we
can rise together I don't want someone
that's down and then I have to pull you
up because I've got a child I don't have
time to be pulling up everyone then
there's a bottle is what are you
bringing to the table well my bringing
to the table
I'm bringing myself
I can do yeah but yeah I bring a lot to
the table why do you hate the question I
hate that question I don't think if
you're interviewing for a job you have
to show them your resume yeah experience
yeah yeah of course but I feel like when
men ask that question
I feel like we should be asking you what
are you bringing to the table because
I've had dinner you want bags you know
what's nice yeah but you're forgetting a
woman is going to first of all she's
going to make your house
she is going to raise your kids most
modern women can make a house a home do
those modern women have recipes from
scratch no no not modern women that have
multiples
not necessarily
not necessarily but what I mean is she
is going to make your house feel like a
home she is going to be there for you
specifically
well you would you would do duties
around the house but not every woman
does that now it's a certain type of
woman you're talking about so like what
I mean personally that a hooker a cook
and a cleaner can't do but she's gonna
be providing you with support
emotionally but I just thought like when
men hear this it's like it's like we're
saying nothing oh okay it's like not
like it's not specific as I can do this
I have the skill this this and this my
mama can do that do you know what it is
obviously there's a lot of my sexuality
and my role is basically like the male
roll so that's why I'm just asking these
little ones and twos to throw you off
but also to get a better understanding
but I don't really hearing
it's not matching up to the 40. I don't
forget why everything's always centered
around finances I understand you need
money to survive but I don't understand
where women have the high expectations
of expecting a man to have so much money
to get with him like how can I thought
like if you love someone it's based on
love like not just based on what you can
pick like like you can take all these
boxes but where's the love in that um
I'll get it one thing I realized from
being in a relationship love is not
enough love is not so you can love life
it's great to be in love but it's not
it's everything peace and love is life I
okay we can say that a man wants peace
when you think about it he wants love
you can be in love with someone love
them dearly but when the bills come is
that love gonna pay them you need to
lower your maintenance then you've got
your high expectations you should be
providing for yourself and you can't
expect the man to do that no but you can
but you've got to do it together for
example okay you live together there's
certain things that a woman May pay and
there's certain things that a man May
pay okay you both work love is not going
to pay those bills love is not going to
keep you woman what you enjoy when you
survive the life of a household together
you survive that's how it works I mean
you become accustomed to the wealth that
you make in your household I get that
but that's that's not the way I would
want to live my life yeah to be able to
enjoy I want to be in love and be able
to say okay so if your man makes more
more than you why should why is he
expected to make more and you make less
and you both live the same it doesn't
have to make more he just said he has to
make more didn't you no no I didn't say
he has to make more I said if I made
more I wouldn't be able to submit to him
he's going to make so he has to make
more we could make the same amount we'd
be happy with the same amount yeah I'd
be happy with the same amount but I find
I'll know if he makes
less than me it would be harder for me
to submit because I just I just that's
how I see it I can't even put a nail on
it but I know if a man-made left you
think Society has a role to play in that
that finances got taken 100 I'm probably
rather than your love life yeah part of
me it's taken do you think Society has
taken a toll on how you love someone
because it's supposed to be love yeah um
no I think it's just the way I see love
I feel like love is not enough maybe
love is based on material then basically
no what I think love is is you can love
someone but maybe uh what can I say so
say you was with a man and he was rich
and then he went broke would you stay
with him 100 because what's the
difference
the difference is because you've gone
broke I didn't meet you bro why can't
you help somebody get rich if you can
have them stay bro yeah because it's a
mentality thing if it could get rich in
the first place then I know in my heart
he can get rich again I believe that I
believe a good man I know it is
personally I get what you're trying to
say a good person can see potential in
somebody from nothing the problem is if
I speak for my personal experiences I am
always the one seeing potential in
people and always maybe there's
something that you should look within
yourself that might need fixing when
choosing a partner then maybe it's not
the man maybe you know what it is maybe
it is but that's why I've made a
decision to say I'm not looking I'm not
going to go with somebody that is I'm
not going to look at anyone's potential
anymore because we can see potential for
days it doesn't mean that they're going
to reach that so what I've learned is I
now want to be with someone or get to
date someone that is at a certain stage
that I can say okay you're not you're
pulling up stage I don't have to pull
you up I think that's very unfair on men
well maybe that is but that's my opinion
that's where I am now I've given people
chances pull them out you want a high
value man I wouldn't say high value but
someone that is like I value yeah
because it's a high value but you've got
a child as well yeah if we're going to
use that term it's 10K a month that's
that's high value
I wouldn't say high value I just want
someone that is able to pay their bills
feed themselves okay so what if a guy
ticked all them boxes and emotionally
you don't feel nothing but besides that
it's absolutely perfect I don't like him
like there's no emotional connection
there's no love there you said love
isn't what you used to be so no I said
love isn't enough so I can love someone
but everything else has you have to be
respectful you have to have to say take
to all them boxes yeah but you love them
a little bit
um
love is important he tips all them boxes
what I think that question was that if a
man ticked all the boxes yeah and you
loved him a little bit is that good
enough
no okay no it's not do you I agree with
you sorry do you think there's a minimum
that like a guy has to have a job right
okay yeah yeah I mean I think I think
it's dishonest when we say It's All
About Love because I think at some point
if a guy's unemployed for five years
you're probably gonna leave I think it's
about the mentality of a person so like
if somebody's broke if I say I met
someone and he's broke but he's got the
right mentality to conquer the world
living by all means I can support him
and I can help him I'm happy to do that
no I I agree with you it's about
mentality but I just think when we're
asking these questions it's like what
what is the minimum
I don't have a moment if I if I like
somebody and I believe in them then they
got my support but how long how long are
you believing in them until they like as
long as I think it's difficult say I
have money and the man doesn't have any
money if he can respect my values and
like believe that I'm putting him in
positions to help him then
I'll support how long if he's getting
off every day at six in the morning and
he's trying and trying you can't fault
somebody like that
I think I've got a whole different
perspective of life because of myself my
lifestyle and how I've been brought up
like what's different about your
lifestyle everything I think my life
upbringing experience is completely
different to a lot of people okay so I
don't really want to dig too deep on him
even being honest but I just do believe
that my circumstances are quite unique
I just don't think money is everything
so what would it take for you not to
believe in him anymore for you to say
okay call my first like perspective of
this man was wrong and he's actually a
like not a bum sorry Bob if he's
behaving like a bum then obviously
that's a huge red red flag that he
doesn't really want to change his life
he's quite happy being mediocre so yeah
so that's when you leave when you
realize his true mentality yeah but I
haven't ever encountered a situation
like that to
say I'm going like okay what were you
gonna say you had something to say
earlier yeah I just um agree with you
sorry I forgot you're lucky
um I agree with you and I feel like what
you were trying to say was
yes your love is you love someone but
it's as a woman it's
conditional and I'm gonna be honest as a
woman like my love is conditional yes I
can love you and yes I can have these
amazing beautiful memories with you but
if you are not bringing those qualities
that I want and you are not going to
contribute to the life that I want for
myself then that love is not enough for
me it's not enough for me and if I'm
honest with you I'm not really looking
to be with someone and do the whole
struggle of things yeah I'll be honest
I'm not I'll agree yes if you have
dreams but it's not my job to sit here
and motivate you and be holding your
hand while you're doing it I'm not
looking for a project I'm looking for
someone who is established because I
feel like as a high value woman I am
allowed to seek a high value man
especially because I know what I bring
to the table so I want someone to match
that can you define a high value woman
to me or to you
um I value woman is someone who first of
all has a lot of respect for herself you
know
um has a lot of like Pride you know
works hard men want prideful hard
workers
hmm
well I I feel like no because men
obviously just want someone who's
beautiful and is just gonna be
submissive and say yes and well that's
at least what we're being told but I
feel like I think that's not true
no men don't like submissive women no I
don't think so no because I feel like
it's not about being submissive you just
have to be kind and you have to be
loving and you have to respect your man
a lot of women don't actually respect
their men yes they like them they're
attracted to them they love them but
they don't actually respect them and I
feel like men want respect from women
and they don't get that enough well I I
agree with you but why is that not
submission isn't that part of submission
no because I still have a voice you
don't think submissive women have voices
I don't know I feel like if I'm just
going to be saying yes to everything and
doing everything that my man wants then
I've kind of lost sense of who I am like
I want to have a voice in this
partnership I want to have a voice in
this marriage and I want to be heard and
I want to be seen But submission is like
he's your boss so your boss can take
your opinion into account but at the end
of the day Here's the final say and men
don't they don't feel like they're
respected if you don't give them the
final say like they don't want a woman
that they have to argue with all the
time yeah but you don't have to argue
with a man to get your point across if
you're with a loving respectful man who
hears you and values you he's always
going to listen to you he can he can
hear you and listen to you and still
tell you no
okay like so that's just because if he
tells me no
it it depends like there's there's
certain things that yeah I might be like
okay cool I'll submit to you because I
would say I'm definitely a traditional
woman and there are you a virgin
I'm sorry I'm saying how are you
tradition a traditional woman is a 22
year old virgin no as in I have like
Traditional Values the way that I was
brought I'm Arab I'm Moroccan we are
brought up in a certain way
um and the men that I see in my culture
are very traditional they're providers
you know they go out they make money and
a lot of women in my culture they don't
work they just sort of stay at home and
the man goes out and gets the money and
they just raise the kids obviously we've
moved on from that but I still hold
those values in the sense that I'm okay
to submit to my man when the time is
right or when I feel the time is right
but the whole point is that's that's not
submission is when you feel I mean we're
women we change our opinions every
goddamn day we don't even know half the
time so it's like if you if if I if I
employ blessing and I say blessing turn
this camera angle on or I do do this do
this and at the end of the day I have
the final say and and that's kind of how
it is should be anyways when you're
submitting to a guy
so so you're saying that's what men want
they just want someone to go yes I'll do
exactly what you tell me to do no they
just want to argue all the time with
every decision
[Laughter]
and just really make you feel heard
wow I feel like yeah I don't know I I
will submit to the right man
um and if I feel comfortable but I will
always have my boundaries set in place
sometimes you're not going to feel
comfortable I mean in a 30 40 50 year
marriage you think you're not going to
feel comfortable
and sometimes you're gonna feel like
he's not the right man I mean every day
yeah 100 so tell me more about the high
value woman what else
I mean the high value woman is like
someone who like is kind who's nurturing
you know
um who's gonna support her man lift him
up motivate him Inspire him
um
you know is is fun she has that feminine
energy that men crave
um you know the list goes on and I know
that men are not stupid they know when
they come across a high value woman they
know
um so yeah do you want to know what I
hear when I hear high value woman oh God
designer
she won all that Instagram like
highlighted Factor like Valentine's Day
you better make sure that like you've
got a hotel with the little petals and
the balloons like holidays it's like
it's like give me everything
to me what I'm hearing when I'm here
they read why a maintenance woman is
it's money in it you need money for that
it's like it's like whenever I hear that
I think of the book why men love
it's like they read that book and then
it's like
that's the whole I'm not saying
personally it's just that's always what
I hear
um okay so what percent of the financial
family load do you guys expect to pay to
carry for a lifetime
ten percent
ten percent ten percent okay
um yeah I would say ten percent
ten percent
I think it changes I think it's like
situational I mean
ideally like
maybe 40
um but I think it changes like you never
know what's gonna happen the man might
suddenly go unemployed so you know I'm
gonna have to pick up extra shifts here
and there and then I might go unemployed
or go on maternity leave and and the
man's gonna take over I think it
fluctuates depending on the situation
um yeah I'm kind of the same there as
well
um I also like as you said like
maternity leave or if I if the man said
that he wanted me to be a housewife
which I don't think I would ever like
take off to do but if he did then I'd
expect him to do 100 then I'll be doing
the cookie and I'll be doing the
cleaning but if like I'm working he's
working like I don't expect him to say
that I'm gonna be a complete housewife
because there's some men that like
I don't know zero percent depending okay
so you think you should carry 100 of the
bills
no that's not true I don't think so I
think I'm just using it okay if I'm
cooking it 50 50 50. okay you okay so we
went from 100 to 50 50. no depending
okay what does it depend on if I'm
working or if I'm not okay do you want
to work or do you not I do
um okay so I would say 50 50. yeah
yeah I I don't I can't think of a
percent
I actually can't been yeah I don't know
are we considering that there's kids
involved here yeah yeah yeah I mean
unless unless you don't I feel like I
want to change my answer now
yeah same I don't know
I don't know what percent all right I'm
just gonna say numbers raise your hand
is there a wide camera do we have one
difficult
that was four I think it's Dependable on
the circumstances though because like if
if you're green that you stay at home
like if I'm staying at home then well
I'm asking if you if you're zero percent
if I'm at home
um
I've had been with my partner and I've
been at home like he wants me at home so
I can't go to work so he's provided for
me all 100 because obviously it's
impossible if I'm a stay-at-home mom but
if she's working
um I think it should be the percentage
should be agreed like in terms of if
they're making the same then I don't see
why it shouldn't be 50 50 if they're
both aren't working
okay
um all right so 50 50. if she's working
yeah do you want to work honestly I like
staying at home I'm a home person okay
if I wasn't in there okay so ideally
zero percent yeah I'm raising the kids
okay and you said ten percent ten
percent yeah
50 50 for me unfortunately you know I
mean that's what I'm looking for 50 feet
okay yeah I would say 10 like if I'm
working
um but if I'm not working then nothing
if you're working 10 percent
yeah okay
I think I'm gonna change it a little bit
like in an Ideal World
I would wanna
be able to go out and do something
part-time to at least contribute a bit
so I'm going to say 20 20 okay
of I think seventy thirteen dollars to
be honest
it's a good one
um go ahead
yeah I'm still I don't know sorry I
can't give a percent what percent of
women do you think get to contribute 20
or less to the family financial load
the ones that own the home
can you say that again what percent of
women do you think get to contribute 20
or less to the family five percent
Housewives I know what percent of women
do you think get to be Housewives
yeah not a lot in the UK or what is it I
mean the way that the UK is right now uh
probably under 10 5 percent
do you guys feel like you're in the top
20 of women to earn that no
want to be able to be a housewife
my circumstances I believe are
exceptional so I don't believe I've been
a housewife and I've lost my partner so
I was a housewife and I feel like my
perspective of life has changed now that
I have the role
of a man in a sense because I have to
provide for my child
so I'm definitely not I'm in tune with
reality hold my position
I'm on the opposite Spectrum so I've
always been the provider and I've got a
little one as well 13 year old so I've
always been the opposite
I've always earned and if I've got in a
relationship I look after
you know what I mean so
it's kind of mad right now me hearing
all these percentages I'm not even gonna
lie
[Music]
okay what about you top 20 of women
uh
I'll just say they'll just have to be
Housewives literally are you top 20 of
women yes sir am I yeah I would be
qualified to be a house okay okay take
all the boxes
top 20 of women yes or no yeah
absolutely yeah
um and you said no
um no no
big up you look man no yeah but I think
I've been a housewife I might be a bit
bored yeah
values qualify or do we want to can you
say which one that's what are you asking
us no I was asking if you think you're
in the top 20 of women
in the eyes of men in the eyes of men
but to be fair with the numbers you
always screaming out you sort of are in
it you wanted to pay 20 you know in an
Ideal World I'd want to pay 20 but we
don't live in an ideal world we live in
the real world and I'm not ignorant to
the fact that I'm not in the top 20 of
women so I don't expect to be a
stay-at-home housewife and have things
how I want
um I don't know where people get the
idea that life's supposed to be exactly
how you want it life is how it is and
you deal with it how you're supposed to
given your circumstances my
circumstances are I'm not top 20 so I'm
probably going to be working what age do
you guys think traditional women get
married by
[Music]
maybe 21 between 21 and yeah before
you're 20 100 so like maybe 19 to 24 25
I would say 20.
yeah
I would say between the age of 21 and 25
21 and 25
25. okay yeah I would have said 25. who
do you guys think benefits more from the
institution of marriage in 2023 men or
women women
yo
no but I don't think it's just money
like I feel like it's like but it's the
institution of marriage not the not the
values of marriage the institution and
women benefit from the institution
massively well I think normally the men
that like earn a lot of money and
they're like the main Breadwinners
sometimes like
um it ended with a lot of domestic like
violence and stuff because they feel
like they're I think that's a bold
assumption okay cool yeah that is a
broad assumption let me just shut up
but still no but I feel like sometimes
like men that make a lot of money they
have a lot more entitlement though I
think it's definitely so does
entitlement equate domestic violence no
not domestic violence but like what do
you mean by entitlement
because they think okay I'm the man
you're the woman I'm earning money and
you're not so whatever I say like goes
it's not a thing where it's like rolls
where it's like okay cool I can respect
that you're cooking and cleaning it's
more of a thing where I'm making the
money and that's that thing but we all
just said that we would have a hard time
respecting someone if we made more money
than them when it comes to decision
making so don't you think if he's paying
all the bills he should have the final
say in decision making yes otherwise go
find a guy to split it 50 50 with yeah
no I feel like he should have the final
like but at the same time as you said
before I feel like there still needs to
be a um conversation Andrew if you're
marrying the right man you'll submit to
him and yeah there should still be and
he'll get the final say but I feel like
a lot of men that are earning they'll
just last thing I have a question
do you want to have a conversation with
your girl about every decision you guys
make nope
so it's like you could feel like that
but guys don't want to do it and it's
kind of like true if the dude's
providing a lifestyle where you get to
be in the top 20.
important decision he can consult you
and I think if you're with a guy for
long enough he's going to consult you
maybe but he also might not that's like
the bosses you know like a boss might go
to their best employee and ask their
opinion but at the end of the day who's
whose decision is it
[Music]
um
and then he doesn't go to the boss and
say you need to have a conversation with
me okay but you keep doing the employee
and boss I think it's very like
different a relationship yeah I mean I
agree I mean it's different but it's the
same way it's the concept yeah
yeah true I get what you mean I I
understand what you mean like if if
that's the lifestyle that we want we
have to kind of be willing to accept
what it comes with but who says that it
has to come with control and like having
to obey someone I don't like that idea
like yes he's providing this life for me
but he's also providing this life for
his kids as well you know and I'm sure
he's the man yeah the man that make the
money say that no I'm I'm saying that he
is obviously providing for his family so
some men are actually happy doing that
they actually want their wife to stay at
home and spend time with the kids and
not it's not a bad thing I'm not I'm not
hating on anyone for wanting wanting
what they want but but what does he get
in return and those guys typically want
submission in return and submission is
and we have to have a conversation every
time I want to I think women are kind of
confused in a sense like you've got the
modern woman who wants to stay they
traditionally like how she is with in
her views but like it's contradiction
it's contradiction contradicting it
um both values because she wants to be a
stay-at-home mom but she still wants to
have a say in the household and fight
for the equality with the confusion of
the feminism thing okay it's like a
challenge sorry let me just jump in
there quickly so for example if
something happens with your kids
um there was an issue in the house
um and for example you and your husband
did not agree on the way that that
situation was dealt with
um
am I not allowed to have a say as as the
wife as the mother of that child yeah or
do I just listen to my husband no matter
what he says even though I feel that
what he's saying is wrong and the way
that he treated our son or the way that
he decided to deal with that situation
it feels like what you're doing is wrong
you both feel that way okay but then we
have to come to some kind of agreement
because that's but feelings are
temporary feelings aren't really I just
think women are emotionally with their
kids and I'm fine men very logical and
it's factual that a man would raise his
child better than a woman so I think you
have to have faith in your partner and
if he's a man you have to give him that
step above to say you know what you're
the man of the household if you don't
have that the whole structure of the
household doesn't have any foundations
really because a woman can't run it it's
impossible and it's a statistics say
that women at single parent households
and things like that are really awful
for children so I think you'd have to
give your man the upper hand at some
point there's no equality in the
household there's the man's role in a
woman's role that's what I believe
and the women and the women that
honestly do lead their households are
miserable yeah I mean you you guys see
the girls that wear the pants in the
relationship do they look happy
that's dressed yeah
that's oh oh gosh I have a question all
right let's say we go back to the
beginning of feminism with the suffrage
movement if you had to fight if your
options
in order to vote was to fight in the
front line of combat would you give it
up
during war times no nope say the
question again please okay so if
in order to vote you had to be drafted
and in the front lines not just like
cooking in the Army go to wall basically
yeah go to war would you still want to
vote no yeah
no no no no I'll stay home
hell no
I'm learning to cook anyway
I'll do anything get me off of the
battlefield
do you guys think the wage Gap exists no
it does it does but it's only what I
don't know eight nine percent but are
you taking into account the time the
amount of time that women are out of
work and the amount of women that work
part-time the majority of men like they
they work full time and they work for a
lot longer than us so the statistics are
saying that there's a wage Gap generally
doesn't make any sense unless you
specify it down to women who are working
full-time and men who are working
full-time because otherwise the
statistics are skewed because
obviously there's going to be a gap in
the wages if a woman is working
part-time and a man is working full-time
and say a woman takes time out to go on
maternity leave or whatever like
I think that statistic is just silly
like if you look at men and women
actually in the same job like my job for
example
guy same age as me both graduates we
earn the same I don't I don't think you
ever walk into a job and the boss
decides she's gonna earn less because
she's a girl I think
maybe there might be a bit of bias when
employing someone do I want to hire say
a 28 year old who's just gotten married
versus say a 35 year old man if I was
the boss you know thinking financially I
would probably pick the man because okay
she's just got married she's 28 she's
not got much time left she's probably
gonna have kids soon and you have to pay
for a mature oh God yeah you have to pay
for like thinking of that from an
employer perspective yeah I gotta pay
for you did not work for six months no I
agree completely yeah and that's the
thing women don't want to do the most
stressful jobs typically and I say this
from like hiring people I've had
situations where I'll offer people roles
here where they'll make like double
triple the amount like but they'd have
to recruit and recruiting's hard and
they don't typically want to do it
and it's stressful because we can't do
the show if you don't do it
but women I don't know they just don't
want to do those jobs exactly and like
if you look at jobs like for example
like labor jobs I mean I don't know a
lot about this
um but you know the majority of women
aren't in labor jobs and people love to
scream oh this is inequality and you
know women aren't welcome in these
industries now be real with yourself do
you actually want to be on a
construction site and the majority of
women don't want to be there so that's
why we're not there but that means
that's actually true you're just going
to stick to yourself that means there
would be a gap in the working industry
with man and woman a wage Gap how would
there be a wage Gap because if a woman
got employed in the labor job same as a
man she would still earn the same so
there wouldn't be a wage she wouldn't
earn the same because she wouldn't be
able to do the job anyway she's not
physically strong enough to do the job
and the boss will see that so he's not
going to pay someone full wage knowing
that she can't even partake the full job
anyway but she's not doing the same
words the guy anyway so it's not
inequality she's not capable of doing
what the man's capable it would be
really unfair to pay her the same and a
man break is without every day and her
get the same money I'll be livid if my
husband come home and as a woman doing
less and he's coming down broken and
like that's just not right yeah no fair
enough I mean I just think like
you usually hear things of people saying
like you know um I went on a podcast
recently and we were discussing
engineering and I was on there with a
girl who was talking about how she was
in engineering and she was really
successful in it like she was actually
like above the majority of men she was
in quite a high power position she she
struggled in that position obviously
because getting a group of men to listen
to you when you're in in an industry
like that is going to be quite hard
um but I just think like
women the majority of the times aren't
in those jobs because they don't want to
be like obviously physical strength is a
limitation of course but I I do believe
that in this day and age if you want to
do something you can go and give it a go
and I think
if a woman wanted to be in the labor
industry she would and could and should
go give it a go but I do agree that well
I'll be honest I'm a build fiber
engineer so I'm the one that's picking
up the Dark Side of everything and
pushing through cables and everything
bringing fiber to people's and do you
earn the same as yours yeah I do I earn
exactly the same so I I want to ask a
question would you guys work in an oil
rig in Alaska for three hundred thousand
dollars a year raise your hand if you
would yeah I would I would it's all
right
purely for curiosity
an adventure but that's what I mean if
you ask a group of guy that guys that
questions half of them are like I'm gone
you know where they're going for the
piece like to get out the crazy
households that exist now like yes
please
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible